you have so much time to live it's your
time you possess it it's your empire
it's your treasure within you and it can
be 60 years it could be 20 years
whatever it is it's yours and you can
inadvertently give it away by wasting
your time by getting involved in
people's trivial fights by working for
other people that you hate they own your
time you have to show up every day at
eight o'clock and you're miserable they
own that thing that is your only real
possession so your goal in life is to
realize that that is your treasure you
don't want to give it away inadvertently
to other people
robert greene welcome the show
thanks for having me chris my pleasure
is it true that you've had more than 80
jobs in your life
well my girlfriend and i once counted
and we got into the 60s right
and then it kind of became a blur and
sometimes i would recall i think i had
this job in college and so we just kind
of estimated upward
but i can at least count 60 in the 60s
of actual jobs and there probably is
more pretty wide ranging
doesn't say great things about me i was
very restless as a young man couldn't
quite find my way i hated working for
other people
more or less that was sort of the gist
of it and i now i've kind of found the
perfect life because i don't have a boss
above me
you were was it 36 when you got the book
offer for
48 laws
well i was 36 when i pitched it to to
the man who packaged at yoast alfred
then we sold it like a year and a half
later so it's probably 37 somewhere
around there yeah yeah it's inspiring
for people that are thinking i should
have my [ __ ] together by the time i'm 30
and still
together but you know yeah it is it is
inspiring you know because
the the lesson that i could tell people
is that i never gave up even in the
worst moments where i was very depressed
and really kind of doubting myself there
was a little voice inside of me that
kept me pushing going forward knowing
that i really was i did have some kind
of talent as a writer i'm not good at
anything else in life but i had some
kind of talent as a writer and that it
was worth you know being keeping keeping
myself keeping a spark to hold the light
and never giving up so that was kind of
my lesson
what's so interesting about power in the
modern era
well
the interesting thing is that people are
so damn hypocritical
so it's i mean this was the case 25
years ago when i wrote the book but
nobody wants to admit that they're
interested in power they like to package
it in all these different forms i just
want to change the world i just want to
make a great movie i just want to write
a great book yeah those those are
motivations for sure and there's always
always a part of it but come on admit
that you love the sensation of power you
love the fact that you have a degree of
control over your own life
that you can that you can more or less
influence the people around you that you
don't feel helpless
but nobody wants to admit it but
everybody is after some form of power
so that's kind of the modern dynamic
things have gotten much more competitive
than they were 30 40 years ago but
nobody wants to admit that they have a
competitive ambitious nature
what's the difference or how do you
differentiate between power and status
i'm not quite sure how you mean that can
you elaborate well people you mean your
your status in life yeah yes
state is just generally as a tool that
permits you access
well you can have the status or status
that's that's how you pronounce it um in
life
you can have a position
of power but you yourself are not very
powerful so power is an inner quality
power is a sense of control over your
emotions a sense of being able to see
into the future and kind of devise plans
for getting what you want being
strategic in life it's kind of thinking
ahead it's a certain form of a
rationality
we find plenty of people in positions of
power and believe me i've worked for
them i was on the board of directors of
american apparel and the ceo was a very
charismatic man but he was
all over the place he had no control
over himself that is not power so you
can have status without power
you can have power without status but
eventually you will get the kind of
position that you want in life if you
have this degree of self-awareness and
self-control at least i believe
talking about the new book which is
daily laws
is there a
romantic arc as sort of a sense of uh
coming full circle with ryan releasing
the daily stoic a few years ago and him
being one of your apprentices not so
long ago and now you
creating a book with that sort of model
assisted by him in the future is that
quite nice to think of it like that yes
it is what it means is my former
apprentice has now outshone me
he's now like more powerful and famous
and successful than i am and now i'm
following in his footsteps but i'm fine
with that because youth rules the world
i'm happy at some point to leave the
stage he's an extremely smart very
brilliant guy and you know to feel that
i am kind of imitating him is is fine
with me i'm very happy with it because i
i love ryan i think it's quite charming
it's quite a nice way to do it so what
i've done is i've stolen a bunch of my
favorite laws from the book so anyone
that's familiar with the daily stoic
your new one the daily laws is one page
a day and you can go through each day
new laws and an insight and sometimes
stories from history or quotes or
whatever and i've gone through and i've
taken some of my favorites and we're
gonna go through them and we'll see how
many we get through today
okay very good all right i'm ready first
one
win through your actions and the law is
demonstrate do not explicate i think
there's a story about sir christopher
wren in here
yeah i mean basically we tend to talk
too much we're very verbal chatty
creatures particularly in the world
today
and it's not a very powerful way to be
if you're in a position where you have
to explain yourself explain why you did
something explain why your work is
better explained why your idea is better
you're already in a weak position right
because
people don't really trust words anymore
right because everybody talks we're
inundated with advertisements with
people who can [ __ ] it with [ __ ]
us with all kinds of words about how
great they are you know it's it's the
era of con men and con women and so
the fact that you can actually
demonstrate your idea through an action
by making people feel that your idea is
superior by making them feel that you're
actually a person of power that you can
make them feel that what you did was the
right thing to do and was justified is
much more powerful and effective than
blabbing a lot of words right and you
know i give in in the 48 laws of power
in that chapter i give you dozens of
strategies for how you can make that
put that to life but that's that's the
general gist of it and chris
story is a pretty much perfect example
of that right
yeah he had these columns in a church
and um
this this critic this other guy who was
who thought he was a great architect and
christopher was the greatest architect
of his time
said you know i don't think there are
enough columns here to support the roof
it's going to fall down and christopher
and goes god what an idiot you know i
mean obviously i know what i'm doing but
instead of arguing with him what he did
was you put in an extra column just like
the guy said
but he left a little space of like six
inches at the top so it actually wasn't
supporting the roof so the guy got the
feeling that he won the argument but in
fact christopher ren had one for the
action because he never did what really
what the guy proposed for him to do
there's a subreddit called r
malicious compliance are you familiar
with this
no
it's phenomenal
it is absolutely outstanding so it's
just people that have been asked to do
certain things and they follow them to
the absolute letter of what's been it's
completely not what the person asked for
but it's malicious compliance it's one
of one of my best reads if you're ever
bored and you need to go down a rabbit
hole on reddit i highly highly
recommend that there's a great novel
written on that very subject by milan
kundura called the joke in which he
people in like a some kind of prison
camp were asked to do these different
tasks and they did them exactly to the
letter but it's a hilarious novel doing
exactly what you're talking about so i
will check out the subreddit malicious
compliance is good right next one next
one uh money and success daily law
concentrate on maintaining a high sense
of purpose and the success will flow to
you naturally
yeah well a lot of people get caught up
in in sort of immediate emotional things
like am i getting enough attention
on on instagram how many followers do i
have am i making as much money as other
people and if you get caught up in your
20s like that you're going to fall that
you're going to end up in a kind of a
dead end in life because really what
brings success ultimate success in life
is kind of realizing something from deep
within
you have a purpose you haven't you
understand that there's something that
you were born to do something that
connects you to your childhood to your
deepest inclinations right and so in
your 20s you're not in a hurry to make
money or increase your instagram
followers to a certain number you're in
a you're in a position where you're
going to learn as many skills as
possible you're going to follow that
purpose which for me was learning how to
write and trying journalism and trying
hollywood etc and you're going to take
your time and you're going to be calm
but intense about that
and then eventually
success will come and when it comes
it's like you're able to then go to the
next step because you know you you're
it's the purpose that guides you not the
money and not the fame so like after i
finished the 48 laws of power you know i
could have gotten all drunk with a
success and i could have could have like
just kind of created the 48 laws of
power part 2 etc but instead i realized
no my purpose is to continually branch
off into other directions to try new
things it's not the money that interests
me i don't mind the money don't get me
wrong i love the fact that i'm able to
make a good living but what really
drives me
is actually fulfilling this deep need
within me to express what i believe is
what i call my life's task you talk
about hyperintention and that sometimes
holding on to things too tightly can
actually cause us to be less effective
at it you say hyperintension cause hyper
anxiousness i think that's something
i've been
considering a lot recently especially
after the last year where everyone's
been locked up ruminating more neurotic
fewer experiences less adventures less
opportunity to get outside of our heads
i think that's certainly something a lot
of people will have been seeing
yeah definitely i mean we all have that
feeling like um
you're trying so hard to get something
and the effort is actually kind of
messing you up right it's kind of
getting in your way like in a seduction
setting if you're so nervous and you
just really really want to please that
woman that you want to seduce and that's
all your energy is going into you're
going to give off vibrations that are
going to be kind of off-putting you're
trying too hard your intention is too
obvious but if you kind of let go it's
more process of letting go inside of
yourself and not in realizing that by
letting go oftentimes when i'm blocked
in my writing
i'm trying too hard if i take a step
back and i relax and i listen to some
great music or watch some football and
television suddenly the idea comes to me
because i let go of that inner tenseness
that kind of envelops you it's difficult
though right because if this is our
life's calling if you've done the
explore period during your 20s and
you're getting toward finding what you
think is your true life's life's calling
you take it seriously and you can quite
easily kid yourself into believing that
the consequences and the repercussions
of your performance can be very grave
this is super important and you start to
grip more and more tightly to what it is
that you're doing it makes you tense and
your performance suffers
yeah i mean definitely but you have to
learn certain strategies of letting go
and it only comes through experience you
know i know um for instance i when i was
writing my war book maybe 14 years ago i
bought a pool table and i thought
shooting pool will be a great way of
relaxing myself right and i'll be able
to learn some strategy and i'll become a
hustler maybe in the end
and so i played every day and i got
better and better and better and then
when somebody would show up to play
against me
suddenly i was just terrible i
completely melted in you know under the
pressure shots that i could normally
make i was bungling left right and
center and it was because i was taking
it way too seriously i was too
invested in winning and then when i
learned to kind of let go and relax and
kind of enjoy the game and not show off
i was actually performing better i
wasn't performing brilliantly don't get
me wrong i'm not at the hustler level
but i was actually performing better
so you learn through experience you
learn through writing seven books
through trying to hustle your way on a
pool table and things don't work out
that you have to take a step back
sometimes and let go it's not easy but
you learn this through experience
next one cultivate negative capability
and the law is develop the habit of
suspending the need to judge everything
that crosses your path consider and even
momentarily entertain viewpoints
opposite to your own seeing how they
feel do anything to break up your normal
train of thinking and your sense that
you already know the truth
yeah well whenever you are facing like a
project or something that you're
creating or building
there's a level of anxiety involved
like you're not quite sure of what you
need to do and you're anxious for
getting the right results etc and this
kind of tightens you up from within and
what happens with most people is before
you start this is really has to do with
your creative process which is extremely
important no matter what line of work
you're in
so when you start your project or or a
problem that you're solving you're
generally only thinking of two or three
possibilities let's say a b or c
and a will be something that you've done
a million times before so you're
naturally going to be thinking doing it
that and b might be something that you
heard somebody else do or whatever and
maybe you'll try that out and c is some
kind of odd thing that you probably will
never try anyway anyway and so you're
going to follow these paths right
because you already assume what you
think is the answer before you've
started
and negative capability is to start with
a different mindset is to let go of that
certainty is to allow yourself to have
something to have some mystery to let
you to tell yourself i don't know the
answer i don't know exactly what the
right path is to follow in fact
a bit flummoxed by it and so instead of
trying a b or c
maybe i should also think of d and e and
f maybe i should look into what other
people have done maybe i should look
into what my enemy the person i hate the
most has done in this situation maybe i
should entertain ideas that i normally
would never entertain and so the ability
to
keep a sense of openness
while also feeling a little bit anxious
about the answer is the essence of
negative capability so you're not in a
rush to get an answer you're let you're
open to all kinds of different
possibilities there's a mozart and
backstory with that as well that mozart
didn't really tend to absorb in many
other artists but with buck for some
reason he did and that actually added a
big flavor to the way that he played
well you know particularly as you get
older and you've had some success you
think that you know the right way you
know the right way to write a book or do
a great podcast or whatever
and so you get kind of closed to other
possibilities right
so in the case of mozart he was like
that but then he was like looking at the
scores of the great composer ba who had
kind of fallen out of fashion by that
time
he was going my god there are actually
things in here that are far superior to
anything i've ever composed it's he's on
another level than i am and so he was
able to drop his ego a very important
part of negative capability and say this
is actually a superior form of music
which was counterpoint he said i'm going
to actually try and incorporate bach
into my music i'm not going to imitate
him i'm going to incorporate his ideas
and it led to a whole new level of
creativity in his career and music
that's that survived the centuries so
the ability also to drop your ego and
admit that other people might have a
better
if sorry go ahead
it's interesting that people can be so
nimble
like that think about the startups at
the moment why you've got companies that
have
less than 50 employees
making that and they're in the ftse
500 or ftse 100
why well it's because they're able to
adapt very very quickly they don't have
these huge diseconomies of scale they're
not these big fat leviathans right that
people need to drag lumbering along with
them they're able to move with the
market and they don't have these
cultural
challenges where the guard rails are
brought in
and then they get bought out by google
or microsoft or amazon and it's all and
they've ruined it and ruined it which is
the sad fate of our world right now but
i completely agree with you on that yeah
yeah all right next one uh remake
yourself into a character of power and
the law is remake yourself into a
character of power working on yourself
like clay should be one of your greatest
and most pleasurable life tasks it makes
you in essence an artist an artist
creating yourself
and there's a story i can't pronounce
this name aurora dupin du
du divante
the novelist that did indiana
uh george sand
yes
the woman yeah
okay
yeah yeah
well it's basically um we're creatures
we're animals that judge people by
appearances and we don't like to admit
that but we pick up vibes from people's
appearance their face their body
language their presence and we kind of
judge them based on that and once we've
judged people that's kind of who they
are in our mind and if you let people
continually kind of pin you down this is
who you are this is who you are chris
this is this is your type etc it kind of
limits your freedom because their
opinion of you will actually constrain
what you can do right your reputation
kind of precedes you and so you want to
turn this around and think of your image
as something that you get to play with
that's something that you get to create
it's like your greatest work of art you
want to take control of the process of
how people can judge you
right which is you think is a little bit
difficult well i should just be who i am
but you're never exactly being who you
are
you're always in some ways crafting your
words and your persona and how you
present yourself depending on the people
you're dealing with and i'm simply
telling you here to take greater control
over that to make it more conscious to
think of yourself as a kind of actor in
this world right and your acting is
you're not just doing anything and just
being yourself but you're learning to
play a role and you're learning to
sometimes change your image right and
some of the most powerful people in this
world you know like a david bowie for
instance or a pablo picasso
they were constantly changing their
image every five or six years it didn't
make them seem crazy it made them seem
incredibly powerful we wanted to see
what is the next incarnation of david
bowie who is he going to be now in the
80s etc it's very powerful right and in
the case of george sand she was a woman
at a time where women novelists were not
very successful and she decided that she
was going to create this image of of a
woman who dressed like a man who almost
had the appearance and spirit of a man
and she took a man's name george
and that became her image and it was
incredibly successful incredibly
powerful it added to her aura as as a
successful novelist so that's sort of
the essence
are you familiar with the theranos story
and elizabeth holmes
yes i am very similar with her right
in what way
she decided that she was going to try
and take on masculine characteristics
she purposefully made her voice lower i
mean she was a complete charlatan and is
going to jail for everyone
she wanted to be she wanted to be steve
jobs etcetera yeah yeah i mean of course
you can it doesn't if you have nothing
to back it up if it's only image if it's
only you know playing a role that's not
going to get you very far there has to
be some substance behind it you know a
david bowie or george sam these are very
talented people who are great artists
right so it's not that you're just a con
artist
so you know you can take that too far
but you know if only
she had elizabeth holmes that had a like
a really brilliant idea that was had
actually foundation all of those black
turtleneck sweaters and that kind of
steve jobs ian appearance
in in her in her pocket whenever in her
you know in the shows that she gave to
deliver a product would have been that
much more effective so it could have
been the right answer here if she had
something to back it up it's the same as
five festival if that had actually
worked
everyone surrounding it would have been
hailed as marketing geniuses and the
same with elizabeth holmes
the one the one in the caribbean which
festival was that yeah fire festival i
think it was oh fire festival yeah yeah
yeah yeah pablo picasa
picasso [ __ ] uh pablo escobar you've
got picasso imagine if it was on pablo
picasso's old island uh pablo pablo
escobar's old ireland and blah blah blah
and the only difference
with both elizabeth holmes and fire
festival the only thing they got wrong
was not having a product that backed it
up
everything else was perfect and people
even if they'd had the minimum viable
they'd scraped that festival by and
people had got and they'd farted out a
half competent music event or with
elizabeth holmes if it had done
50
or 70 of what it was supposed to they
would be hailed as
the second coming
right look at the gap they found in the
market because we applaud success so
much we're so happy to put it on a
pedestal because this person's got the
new idea and there'll be young girls
going to school and mothers would be
dressing them in black turtlenecks
because you want to be just like
elizabeth holmes
it doesn't change the fact
that she
the way that those
marketing strategies have been deployed
and the fundamentally predatory nature
of the people that were deploying them
hasn't changed all that's changed is the
fact that they had something finally to
back it up i think there's there's
something really worrying
to do with that this sort of cult of
personality that we have at the moment
in the 21st century
yeah it could be very dangerous as i
said you know when i wrote the 48 laws
of power
um people kind of scratch their heads
and they say why do you have so many
stories about con artists well i say
we're living in the era of con artists
and that's going to be our future where
people are kind of trying to fake their
way to some kind of power the con artist
isn't necessarily doing an actual con
game on you like the traditional con
games and getting your money they're
trying to make you think that they're
more competent than they are that
they're more powerful than they are
politicians are are largely con artists
these days you know so yeah that's i
sort of see that
as kind of the future of power in some
ways
next unfortunately next one next one
next one uh do not be the court cynic
and the law is the ability to express
wonder and amazement and seem like you
mean it is a rare and dying talent but
one still greatly valued
yeah well you know a lot of people in in
in the work world think that they can
just kind of be whoever they are and if
they have a kind of a sarcastic sardonic
humor but that's you know that's just
natural and people are going to love
that kind of thing
and you know we're phil we're surrounded
by people who are generally the world
has become increasingly more cynical
where people doubt everything and
everything is a conspiracy theory and
everything everybody has an ulterior
motive etc and sort of to kind of drop
that
and to actually feel the opposite to
feel that people might be sincere in
what they're doing that they might have
a good reason for believing what they
are to being open to their spirit
instead of being closed and cynical and
skeptical about things to having a sense
kind of a childlike aura in which you're
excited by the world and you're in awe
of things and you think that people have
interesting ideas you're going to try
and get inside their ideas
is an incredibly seductive tactic it's
incredibly powerful because it's so rare
in this world where everybody thinks
they have the right answer and everybody
else is so stupid
so
dropping the kind of cynicism
and kind of opening yourself up to the
uh the spirit of other people is exactly
what you need in the kind of modern
court worlds that we live in
superbly disarming
yes
yes
very well do you have chris oh thank you
yeah i am
when i'm on the internet the number of
times that you watch people have a
discussion and they're fighting
backwards and forwards and entrenching
themselves in their position and if
someone does come in and say
wow that's really interesting can you
link me to something about this so that
i can learn more the entire argument
gets muted there done yeah
what is it it's a show of faith it's
them saying i am here in good faith i'm
here because i genuinely want to
understand your point of view everyone
is convinced of their own points of view
like it's not that they have your
information and they're choosing to
disregard it so that they can never no
they have their own point of view you
have yours if you want to understand the
world from their perspective you just
need to if you had their stuff you would
believe it as well minus some biases and
life experiences but
yeah i it's super disarming and it
you're right i think
making that balancing act between
uh how would you say avoiding cynicism
and remaining sufficiently aloof
uh and not uh sycophantic
that's that's a delicate balance to play
yes you have to have a slight level of
detachment where you know you you kind
of analyze the situation and determine
that maybe their idea is a little bit
bogus but at least you're going to make
the ever going to take that step forward
to try and understand them in some way a
lot of people
mistake cynicism for intelligence for
for intellectual capacity if i
disbelieve everything that must be a
sign
that i'm so brilliant because i'm ahead
of the curve i can think of exactly
what's wrong in your idea but that's not
the case at all the greatest scientists
in this world and i interviewed one of
them for my book mastery ramachandran vs
ramachandran said
so many scientists begin now with that
kind of skeptical attitude and he wants
to oh he wants to have the opposite
attitude that he had when he was a child
that he's in wonder of all the things
going on in this world and he doesn't
know the answers and that's what
precisely will lead lead to some great
discoveries so cynicism is not
intelligence in fact i think it's kind
of a closed mind
just because you have a heterodox
opinion doesn't mean that you're smart
right yeah right next one uh judge them
on their behavior not on their words
what you want is a picture of a person's
character over time restrained from the
natural tendency to judge right away and
let the passage of time reveal more and
more about who people are this is
something i see play out
pretty much every single year that i
exist on this planet
well um you know i do a lot of
consulting work with people in various
lines of work in uh you know sports in
politics entertainment etc
and the number one problem that people
have is
they've hired someone a business partner
a manager an employee to help them
and it ends up they're a disaster
you know they're like trying to get the
company away from them they're just so
incompetent i had no idea you know tell
me robert how can i how can i get out of
this well i'm going to tell you how to
get out of but first i'm going to teach
you the number one thing is never hire
these fuck-ups in the first place and
the reason you're hiring them is because
you're judging them on their appearance
on their dazzling resume on their
charming smile on the cool clothes that
they're wearing right and they kind of
charm you and they kind of con you with
their appearance
and that's sort of the the animal part
of our nature where we're kind of
dazzled by how things look
you need to look below the surface
character is something that's etched so
deeply in people they almost cannot
control it it's what creates patterns of
behavior in their life that is who they
are
some people have a good character and
some people have a very bad character
and instead of good or bad i like to say
strong or weak
strong character the people who can take
criticism right that's the number one
thing you want in somebody that you're
hiring or working with or even an
intimate partner you want to be able to
criticize them criticize them on some
level in a constructive way if they
can't take any criticism it shows a
weakness in character and you're never
going to be able to work with them on
any level you also want strong character
people who can handle stress
so many times these people hired someone
who seemed so great and then the [ __ ]
hit the fan and they kind of withered
and turned to these whiny little
five-year-olds right
well
stress reveals people who people are and
i instruct people you can't put people
in stressful situations right now but in
the interview process you can make them
sweat a little bit you can make them a
little bit nervous you can put them in a
little bit of stress to see how they
react and i show you how what what is
the proper reaction what isn't in those
kinds of situations you want people who
can work as a team who are not so so ego
driven and everything is about them who
kind of subsume their ego and work with
others these are signs of a strong
character the opposite is weak character
stop looking at the resume at the smile
at the pretty close at the charming
words and get under that surface and
look at their character because that is
really what is going to determine
you know how well you can work with them
and work choosing people of bad
character is going to make your life
hell believe me i've been dealing with
this for for 25 years in my consulting i
have a lot of stories about that so
very important i was talking to a navy
seal and he brought up a really nice uh
dichotomy around how people hire and
fire so that people hire based on skills
so they look at someone's resume and
they have this particular qualification
and this was their last job and so on
and so forth but they fire people based
on their attributes
so it's not the fact that they weren't
able to do the job he uses as a navy
seal example he said look chris if you
said to me um i want
to be able to hit a target at 25 yards
with a handgun he's like give me a
couple of weeks i can teach you to do it
that'll be fine that's a skill what i
can't teach you is how to take criticism
or how to be uh how to have humor or how
to have empathy or how to be a team
player how to be resilient or have grit
or blah blah blah blah blah
so you hire people based on the skills
then realize that they might have the
skills that you require but their
attributes and their personality and
their character are completely sideways
because during any 90 minute interview
you can't see you can't stress test the
character so yeah i would be um
i think that's a really good way to try
and make someone sweat purposefully to
create some discomfort well so when you
do that when you do that you want to see
whether they they can say something like
you know
actually chris i don't know the answer
to that that's a good question let me
think about it or no the the the idiot
the the bad weak character response is
you know to get all defensive and say
well you know blah blah blah and blame
other people or say you know trying to
justify why your idea is the best you're
already revealing that kind of
underlying inability to take some kind
of criticism
so yeah
those people that
struggle
to
sit with that discomfort
even if it's just in an interview and do
get defensive and do start to bluster
it's
you know that's the
pebble at the top of an avalanche i
think and something worse is going to
happen down down the road
yeah i mean so don't don't look at the
resume so much don't look at whether
they went to some great business school
try and see patterns in their past look
at that resume for certain patterns
right so if they were continually being
fired
every
couple of years from some job and they
say oh i had this boss was terrible et
cetera no look at maybe that there's a
pattern that's kind of recurring in
their life and it's going to recur with
you and the next next time it goes
around
so
be focused not on the skills and the
glittering resume but what on people are
trying to disguise because if people
have weaknesses in their character
they're doing everything they can to
disguise it from you unconsciously
they're doing that in the interview in
the initial process right and then
months later it'll it'll leak out right
so you want to be a detective and you
want to get under that facade
use absence to increase respect
the more you are seen and heard from the
more common you appear
if you are already established in a
group temporarily withdraw from it that
temporarily withdrawing from it will
make you more talked about even more
admired you must learn when to leave
create value through scarcity and
there's this napoleon quote where he
says if i am often seen at the theater
people will cease to notice me
right i mean it's very counterintuitive
to our social media age where we think
the only way to gain power is to be
immediately present continually every
single day
on instagram or whatever it is with the
new tick tock video never letting one
hour go by where people aren't clicking
on you right so it's kind of a hyper
you know a mood that we're all caught up
in it's very infecting
and it's not based on on real psychology
so if you're so much in people's face if
you're continually there
they're naturally going to grow tired of
you they're naturally going to think
that you're kind of weak that you're
trying too hard for attention they may
not say it but they feel it a slight
level of contempt from within right
and so if you disappear for a day or
several days or a week people are going
to start thinking about you and they're
going to wondering well maybe i didn't
really know chris maybe he's a little
more mysterious and dimensional than i
thought of maybe there's something going
on maybe he's disappeared for this
reason or that and as they think about
you and as they may be fantasized about
what's going on in your mind
it's kind of creates a sort of a
seductive process where their your
spirit is entering their head as opposed
to them being so filled with you that
they want to vomit and get rid of you
you're creating an appetite where they
want to like now know more it's an
incredibly powerful dynamic and so in it
in a dating situation it's extremely
obvious that's the most obvious of all
so if you're continually bombarding
people with texts
you know love bombing them i love you i
need to see you blah blah blah blah
people might initially think that's kind
of cool you know i i don't get enough of
that but after a couple of days it
starts to get a little bit tiring and
you begin to wonder about the other
person maybe they're desperate maybe it
has nothing to do about me maybe they're
just desperate right and so you know but
if
they've created this pattern where
they're texting you and then suddenly
they don't
for a day or two you're going wow maybe
i've done something wrong maybe they
don't like me as much as they like me
before and now you makes them want to
try harder to please you
so learning how to absent yourself in
this social media age is extremely
important and it's not easy i know
where you're trying to always post
something on instagram it's not just
absence it's just creating a sense of
mystery
so people have the sense that they don't
thoroughly know you so that they can
disdain you right you want to keep them
on their toes and occasionally do
something unpredictable that will
surprise them that's sort of the art
here there's two things that i really
like about this the first is the pattern
interrupt that you have that makes
people realize oh hang on there's
something different to what i'd expected
here and the next one is the scarcity
creating demand that you use the example
of the tulips that
bubble market
and
that like demand was simply created
through scarcity and think about anyone
that you kind of admire
some of them may be
omnipresent but the ones that are
omnipresent have to be so talented and
so likable that they're constantly
delivering you something that's very
very nice and even they will be patent
interrupting by supplying you with
something that's slightly different it's
always worded a little bit more and
they're always sort of forward thinking
and creative but the people that are
aloof
they're the ones that have this sort of
mystique and they're kind of like
mysterious and attractive and you don't
really know what's going on with them
right right very much so i mean we lived
through that with with donald trump here
in the united states where he was so
much in your face that it was just like
you you know you couldn't avoid it even
if you didn't want to think about him
you were thinking about him night and
day and initially it was powerful in a
perverted sense he captured so much of
our attention but eventually so many
people got tired of it even his own
supporters got tired of the daily tweet
etc and it really turned against him
because he didn't know he i didn't know
how to do your patent interruption
that's what you call it you know he
didn't know how to surprise or do
something different because it was his
character that made him always do the
same thing
and he didn't never ever knew how to
absent himself so you know these are
these are powerful lessons and there are
people like an elon musk
who doesn't really upset himself very
much but he is kind of keeping us on the
toes we never quite know what he's up to
next you know he can he can do that
patent interruption that you're talking
about
appear to be an object of desire build a
reputation that precedes you if many
have succumbed to your charms there must
be a reason
yeah i mean it's i'll give people a very
banal example
you're looking for a restaurant you're
with your your friend your girlfriend
boyfriend and you pass by a restaurant
it looks kind of nice but there's only
one couple sitting at a table in a
rather vast room and you go
hmm even though you don't admit it you
can no let's not let's try let's look at
somewhere else and you pass by this
restaurant it's packed with people that
are all laughing and drinking you go
yeah let's go in there there must be a
reason right
so a lot of our human desires are based
on what other people are desiring right
they've been very interesting
intellectuals have written about that
the memetic the imitating aspect of our
desire if other people think something
is cool there must be a reason for it i
must think maybe i should think that
it's cool as well right
so you want to continually create
triangles of desire where the product
that you create or the person that you
are is desired by so many other people
that it creates a kind of a viral effect
and attention is brought to you so um
i don't like to often admit this but
i'll tell the story about how i seduced
my current girlfriend
um we've been with for quite a while
um it was like my birthday we had
already had two dates
and i didn't think she was that into me
i wasn't quite sure you know the level
of interest in me
so
this is before i wrote the art of
seduction i have to admit so i invited
her to my birthday party knowing full
well that eight of these really
beautiful women would be there who
happened to be my friends at the time
right they were gonna be all around the
table and i knew that seeing that she
would immediately seem assumed that
these women were kind of interested in
me or that there must be something
enticing about robert to have attracted
all of these beautiful women it could
have been totally fake they were just
friends of mine but it worked as a charm
and she admits it to this day so um
creating triangles of desire is
extremely important this will even if
it's a product that you that you've
created or in a seduction facet you know
and i talked about in my last book about
the french designer coco chanel who was
really brilliant at that
whenever she created some design some
new kind of outfit or whatever she made
sure that
women saw other women wearing her
outfits everywhere she purposely hired
models to do that wow
other women are buying this i have to be
interested in it so even in a marketing
sense you want to
continually create these viral effects
yeah mimetic desire is a hell of a drug
there was um
wasn't there something
a marketing campaign that was done with
cigarettes
and women
wasn't it seen unbecomingly to for women
to smoke for a while and then they got
models and they paid models to walk down
some street in new york and i got this
right yeah that this was edward bernice
i talked about that in the art of
seduction he was a a cousin of sigmund
freud he was one of the most brilliant
public relations people in history
and he created this like liberty march
that was in which
women walked down fifth avenue in in
mass smoking cigarettes and it wasn't
now this kind of dirty little thing that
that loose women did it was now a
liberty a liberty thing a liberating
thing it's great for women here in the
1920s it's a new era but it's not just
one woman in a dark corner it was like
hundreds of them marched down the street
all smoking and it had it was immensely
effective it's one of the great
advertising campaigns of the modern era
didn't they call them was it like
freedom torches or something that even
given them a cute little name
i think so i think you're right yeah
it's been a long time since i did that
story i have no idea where i've pulled
that story from i've totally brought
science from my book
there we go right next one next one uh
time is all you have resist the urge to
respond to trivial annoyances time lost
can never be regained
yeah well i talk about this i don't know
if it's the same law i talk about
dead time versus live time
and what i mean by that is
um
you know
you
you have a lot of possessions in this
world you have your car your house
you know the money that you've saved etc
etc all these things even your loved
ones can eventually be taken from you
and they will be taken from with you at
some point in life because that's the
nature of our transient existence
the one thing the one thing that you own
that can never ever be taken away from
you ever until you die is your time
right so when you're born
you know when the and the faith cut the
umbilical cord is cut
you have so much time to live it's your
time you possess it it's your empire
it's your treasure within you right
and it can be 60 years it could be 20
years whatever it is it's yours right
and
you can inadvertently give it away
by wasting your time by getting involved
in people's trivial fights
by working for other people that you
hate
they own your time you have to show up
every day at eight o'clock and you're
miserable they own that thing that you
is your only real possession so your
goal in life is to realize that that is
your treasure and it's something that
you own and you want to make it your own
you don't want to give it away
inadvertently to other people so let's
say
you're working at that [ __ ] job and you
have that horrible boss and you're
miserable right that time that you have
there those eight hours is what i call
dead time it's like something that was
originally kind of green and started
turning brown and withering and dying on
the vine that's died within you it's
totally brown right and you're miserable
and you're resentful and you go home and
you're bitter etc
you can turn that around and make those
eight hours a live time you tell
yourself all right this isn't my future
i'm not going to be flipping burgers at
mcdonald's forever okay so maybe when i
go home at night i'm going to start
studying something i'm going to go to
night school i'm going to create a
different plan for my life all right
also the people in this restaurant maybe
there's some interesting psychologies
going on even with my co-workers maybe i
can learn something about how to deal
with people maybe i can learn what my
weaknesses are
maybe i can develop some kind of empathy
with it maybe i can see that there are
things that i can learn even from the
worst possible job
suddenly that dead brown time starts
turning green and green and little
sprouts start showing up on the tree
limb right so that's how you create a
lifetime by saying it's mine i'm going
to create something worthwhile out of it
i'm not going to give it away to others
i'm not going to be sucked into their
dramas and their and their games that
they try and get me to play with this is
my time i'm going to own it
i spoke to a friend on the show and was
sad about the fact that i used to have a
very small minor existential crisis
every time i went to the supermarket
after work at three in the morning so i
was working in a nightclub and then
finish up and then it would be 3 or 3 30
a.m and i'd realized i didn't have any
food for tomorrow or there's no milk or
whatever
and i'd go into the supermarket and it
was just the perfect amalgamation of
fatigue
and
hunger and what the [ __ ] am i doing in a
supermarket at 3 30 in the morning uh
and i just used to always feel a bit
sort of
wistful or melancholy or whatever and i
said to him and he's like
do this the next time that you go in
when you go in someone that's stacking
the shelves or the person that you speak
to at the counter like just genuinely
care for 30 seconds about how their day
is going
like invest yourself in them and say hey
man like how how are you doing tonight a
little bit late isn't it like is
everything okay
uh and it made me realize i was like
look if you focus your energy outward
not inward you are going to sort of free
that and open it up a little bit and it
made a big difference
yeah that's very true i agree with that
100
right next one the madness of groups
never relinquish your ability to doubt
reflect and consider other options your
rationality as an individual is your
only protection against the madness that
can overcome a group
well what often happens is if you're an
individual
and some and you're entertaining an idea
you might be a little bit skeptical and
you might tell yourself
maybe that's not the best idea maybe
after a couple hours you see from
another angle and you go
now you know maybe i shouldn't follow
that path that doesn't seem quite right
but in a group setting the very opposite
happens
when a group starts entertaining an idea
that ability to step back and detach and
to analyze it suddenly goes out the
window
right because other people are focusing
on this idea and you get caught up in
the group mentality and suddenly
everybody is signing off on this idea
and not reflecting on the possible
negative consequences so if you're an
individual and you choose a particular
path
and it fails you're going to pay
terrible consequences the stakes are
high so naturally you're going to think
more deeply about the possibilities but
when you're in a group
and the boss is advocating some kind of
ridiculous scheme that everyone's kind
of buying off on the back of your mind
you go if this is wrong if it [ __ ] up
well i'm not going to blame because it's
everybody else there so all these kind
of group mentalities start kicking in
and it's kind of a madness it's a kind
of delusionary process if you as an
individual went through that delusionary
process you would be homeless your life
would be a complete wreckage right now
right if every time you thought of some
idea you immediately convinced yourself
it's brilliant it has to work and i'm
not going to pay any consequences you
would probably be dead but in a group
setting you can get away with that oh
yes and and how many hollywood meetings
when i worked in hollywood before that
did i actually see with my own eyes this
very dynamic where some really bad
script was being entertained by some
producer but because the producer liked
it everyone was now like
felt the need to kind of say yes i think
it's pretty good even though everybody
knew it was a [ __ ] script and suddenly
this thing that you thought was the
worst movie that ever was this first
script that was ever written is now
being passed into production it's going
to happen
and nobody in that group meeting kind of
raised their hand and said
you know
mr producer i think there's some things
that really need to be changed i think
the whole idea is actually pretty rotten
it's not going to work very well if one
person had done that then maybe
something had changed but the whole
group signs off on it and this really
pathetic stupid movie actually gets made
believe me i saw that time and again so
groups have a kind of madness a kind of
delusionary process where the
consequences of what you of what could
have go wrong are suddenly spread out
about so many people and you get drawn
in to the kind of group mentality where
it's natural you don't want to be that
one person saying no i don't think this
might be so good because you're going to
be maybe be ostracized people are going
to wonder about you so it creates this
kind of insanity dynamic in the group
and it's very dangerous what's the
solution then as an individual how do
you play that game
well as an individual you have to have
well first of all the most important
thing this is what i do in my consulting
i'd say
it really starts from the boss from the
person who's like going to spread the
bad idea among the group right that you
have to realize that you don't want a
bunch of yes men and yes women around
you you want to create a dynamic in
which people can raise their hand and
say this idea is [ __ ] mr boss even
though you might fire me
that's a sign that's a strong character
that we're talking about so it really
starts at the top right where that
person is able to create a group dynamic
where some kind of air from the outside
is let in and people can actually
express some of their true opinion and
if you're caught in that kind of dynamic
where it's the boss is like that that's
very dangerous and very delicate because
your job might be on the line
so
maybe you kind of sign off on the group
dynamics so you're not fired so you
still can have a paycheck and pay for
your food and clothing etc but in your
mind you don't go you don't seduce but
you create some distance you go i know
this is a bad idea i'm not going to get
sucked into it i'm not going to get
personally involved in it and in any
time in the process if i can bring in a
little word of criticism or a little
breath of fresh air i'm going to try and
do it i'm not going to emotionally
invest myself in this group madness
suffer fools gladly detach yourself
emotionally from fools and while you're
inwardly laughing at their foolishness
indulge them in one of their
more harmless ideas this one i thought
was quite interesting
well it's one that i'm not so good at
myself and i've worked at it over the
years
um because i've hired people who are
quite honestly very incompetent who end
up you know
i violated my own law here about
character
and i and i
admit it
and
they're incompetent
they're lazy
and they're foolish
and man it gets under my skin and well
man i want to beat the [ __ ] out of them
man it's hard for me to control my
emotions
but i try i try very hard and part of
the strategy that i talk about in suffer
fools gladly
is to take a step back and realize
you are probably a fool yourself right
you chris williamson have a foolish side
to himself
you play the fool sometimes even though
you don't want to play the fool
me robert you sometimes can be very
foolish and very stupid even though you
wrote the 48 laws of power you often
violate the 48 laws of power there's a
side of you that is quite foolish and
quite emotional and quite reactive
despite how great you think you are
and when you have that you're dealing
with someone that's getting under your
skin who's got really bad ideas who
doesn't working hard enough
although it's hard for me when people
don't work hard enough because i can
excuse bad ideas and other things but if
you're not working hard enough that's
really hard for me but anyway feels very
much within someone's control right
exactly but beyond that if it's people
they're just like not very bright and
they they're kind of slightly
incompetent have a little bit of empathy
maybe you don't want to work with them
maybe you're trying to find a way not to
be involved in their life in a way
that's going to
have terrible consequences for you but
maybe have some empathy by focusing on
the fact that you're not as great and
smart and wise together as you think you
are that we all have a foolish side to
ourselves so that's how i've kind of
been able to kind of overcome the fact
that i don't suffer fool's clown
i think it stops us from feeling so
caught up in
the natural vicissitudes of other people
trying to do their
just go about their days there's all of
those people that you hate follow online
the only reason that you follow them is
because their life is a slow motion car
crash and we've all got those it's this
odd catharsis that we have by knowing
that someone else's life is consistently
[ __ ] you think yes yes mess up again go
on and
i don't know i feel like if we were able
to detach and kind of laugh
more
because it's all well and good having it
with that one or two people that you
follow online but when it's someone that
you're a little bit more invested in you
that equanimity is completely out of the
window and you go okay let's try and
take some of that mindfulness let's try
and bring that over into someone else
one thing that i had in my mind i once
read a story and i don't know if this is
true
about
um when you wrote the 48 laws of power
did you purposefully make it slightly
less applied or
applicable to um people being able to
deploy them because you had concerns
over how much people were going to
manipulate the laws in the real world is
there any truth to this
well um they i did want to um
kind of keep it open-ended and
the real point of the 48 laws of power
was to open people's eyes who are a bit
more like myself who are a bit more
naive and innocent
who enter the world with a bit of that
foolish side that i mentioned them and
that certainly was me when i was in my
20s
right i suffered a lot i violated these
laws i was observing people of power so
when i wrote the book it wasn't with the
intention
of helping [ __ ] become even better
[ __ ] it was with the intention of
protecting people like myself from
having to continually deal with [ __ ]
and not being so naive in my dealing
with them and being aware of kind of the
games and manipulations that they play
so i wrote the book from that kind of
schlemiel perspective if you will from
that outsider perspective
and you know at times i would catch
myself kind of
not doing that so much and then i would
go return to that and so i tried to
build it into the way i wrote the book
where when you read about
um get others to do the work but always
take the credit which is what happened
to me 90 times in hollywood
i wrote it in such a way that you
wouldn't feel like
this has happened to me this is what
other people are doing to me i better be
aware of it so i was trying to get
cues to the reader this isn't
necessarily what you want to do it's
what you want to be aware of or create a
cult-like following you know plan
people's need to believe to create i'm
not trying to literally tell you how to
create a cult although i am actually in
fact i'm saying we live in a world of
cults now they're everywhere they're
political cults you don't call them
cults but they are cults and this is a
key to how you can decipher what is a
cult and what is not a cult
so i may have failed in some chapters
but that was my lofty goal all right
last one
accept your insignificance the fact that
you were aware of this insignificance
and smallness is paradoxically what
renders you powerful and significant it
is an understanding of reality that no
other animal is capable of such
awareness can begin to restore you to
that sense of awe and connection that
comes from a proper sense of scale
well this is a
very
powerful thing to me right now because
it's the book i'm currently writing and
it's currently what i'm immersed in so
it has great emotional resonance
resonance with me right now
and the idea is
when you were a child and you were
physically quite small everything around
you was larger right your parents were
larger the house was large animals were
large rooms were vast
and
because of that it created a certain
mentality where you were kind of
slightly frightened but also in awe of
things you were aware that you were a
small weak creature and it made you
curious it made you your way to kind of
get a little bit of control was to
understand through knowledge to be
curious to read books to be interested
and one and being kind of awe continual
of the world that's around you right
because in truth this world is insanely
awesome and that's what i'm explaining
in my new book
but how weird and perverted is it that
as we get older the kind of dynamic gets
reversed where everything that used to
be so much larger now seems smaller and
it's as if like we're gulliver and now
we've grown and grown and grown and
everybody else is now smaller around us
and we're these giants it's our ego
everything revolves around us our
desires our beliefs you know it just it
just is is so much superior to anything
else right and so suddenly the universe
that is vast kind of starts shrinking
down oh yeah i know about the sun the
moon the star that's all the science
[ __ ] i know i've heard about the big
bang yeah yeah yeah i know about
evolution yeah yeah okay i this is
something to be excited about like when
i was a child because i'm so much bigger
now i have understanding it's pure
[ __ ] you don't have any idea you're
not any bigger the relationship between
you and the cosmos is still you're
insanely small
do you know that the big bang occurred
maybe 13 billion years ago can you try
to compare your 70 years perhaps or 80
years of existence to 13 billion do you
know how small that is do you know how
small it is you're a little you know
five foot six feet of space that you
occupy compared to the vastness of the
cosmos you are incredibly small and when
you die
within several decades people have
completely forgotten about you
they won't remember anything about chris
williamson or robert greene right
so you're as small as you were in a
child all that's changed is you think
that you're much larger than you are and
so the process is to slowly shrink
yourself back down to the reality and to
look at the world and realize this world
is actually as even more awesome than i
realized as a child
you know
i i did a lot of science for that
particular chapter that i'm reading
about
and to read about the big bang
is one of the most earth-shattering
experiences this man who wrote a book
called the first three minutes a great
physicist
i forget his name he died recently
he described the first three minutes of
the universe as best he could now
probably in a hundred years it'll all be
seen as nonsense but the thought
of what was actually going on from this
tiny kernel this thing that was that was
our universe was so small
it was nothing and then it kind of
explodes and then it expands in the heat
and and the look and the feel of it and
the power of it
like whoa
whoa just to think about that was like
put everything else in my life in
perspective and then kind of flow from
that to the evolution of the cosmos or
to think about i'll leave you with one
last thought here chris
is
you know life on earth sparked maybe
two some billion years ago whatever
scientists decide upon
um
and then there were all of these like
little bottlenecks in which the way life
evolved as it is today might have
happened very very differently
incredibly little chance encounters the
first chance encounter might have been
the first spark of life in a little pool
somewhere on the planet but then there
was this thing where
multicellular organisms suddenly were
created right
and it's only happened once in the
history of our cosmos because we know
because there's only one line of dna for
all organisms on the planet one organism
one piece of bacteria ate another one
and created the first complex
multicellular form of life and it only
happened once and it was like a freakish
occurrence if it had never happened it
would just be a planet full of bacteria
right i could go on and on and on the
disappearance of the dinosaurs 60
million years ago when a asteroid hit
our planet and destroyed everything and
killed off all the dinosaurs and that
asteroid nearly missed our planet if it
had missed it'd still be dinosaurs all
around the world and we wouldn't be here
and so
you know and then you go through the 70
000 generations of people prior to your
being born
think of how odd it was that your two
parents met
and how unlikely it was well multiply
that by 70 000 going back all the way to
your ultimate
your first ancestors so you being alive
you being having two legs two arms and a
brain
is so astronomically unlikely so just
think of that every day and think of how
small and think of how insane it is just
to be alive so that's sort of the point
of returning to that initial smallness
that i was talking about
all the way to finish robert greene
ladies and gentlemen daily laws will be
linked in the show notes below where
should people go if they want to keep up
to date with the other things you're
doing
oh hold on with me one second
just bear with me because all right
i have a new website that i'm supposed
to promote and i
and i bollocks it every single time and
now i told this guy
huh nice use of bollocks i'm a big fan
of that
very anglo-sized
okay
um
all right i'm supposed to say my website
is
robertgreenofficial.com
has links to all my books and social
media
didn't sound scripted didn't sound
scripted at all
it's completely scripted you nailed it
you nailed it look uh i really really
think that you've done a great job with
this it's going to be
an absolute smash it's linked in the
show notes below everyone can go and get
it there until next time robert thank
you
thank you so much for having me chris i
really enjoy it take him thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few months and don't forget to
subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace